this is um this is just the first
question just we're just going to set it
up and we're anything into about
velocity we get to acceleration which as
you'll see later on is substantially
more confusing but that's why we're
going to give it some time we'll just
start with velocity okay so they tell us
in a particular situation though the
velocity is it's just a constant it's
just six and then they give us an
initial condition right so then they say
can you come up with T in terms of X and
X in terms of T so they want both
through because we're sort of in this
in-between spot where we know how to
look at things in with respect to time
and we also know how to look at things
with respect to displacement so how do
we think about this normally well V V by
definition is DX on DT it's half
displacement is changing with respect to
time so it's equal to six
yeah now how would I then go from here
to getting X in terms of T you can do
this you don't need any fancy schmancy
like extra knowledge to do this how do
you get from a derivative to your
original equation I'm going to integrate
but but note here with respect to time
okay you have to pay close attention
this is why I talked before about why X
dot next double dot you need to know
what they are but I avoid writing them
because when I want to write what's
going on I want to make it really clear
and I want to think really clearly about
what I'm differentiating or integrating
with respect to okay so what I can do is
I can say well from this equation X
should be equal to the integral of 6
with respect to time that okay that's
not soup that's not too game-changing
right so of course this is an indefinite
integral which means I should have 6
help me out Michael what do you see and
it's indefinite which means I need to
add a constant fantastic so you can see
at this point why they have provided us
this initial condition because it will
help us find out what this constant is I
can substitute it back in I can say when
T equals 0 x equals 1 therefore 1 goes
over here on the left this is going to
be 6 lots of 0
see so now I know what my constant is
therefore I can say this is displacement
in terms of time okay now then they say
okay well how do I get it the other way
around now in this case it's a nice
simple equation so all you could do is
you could say well at this point I'm
just going to rearrange this equation
I'm just going to change the subject
that would be fine okay however two
pointers that I want to make firstly you
can't always do that because I only got
this equation from knowing this initial
condition if you do not know the initial
condition then you cannot go through
this process cause you can't find out
what C is and then you've got no
equation to rearrange okay so that's the
first issue secondly sometimes you just
it's just quicker if you want to go
straight to this place man rather than
going to displacement through this like
sort of backdoor right through time I
can go directly there if I come back to
this line here
I should done that in another color so
see this equation right it's DX on DT
but I can change this not to be a
derivative with respect to time I can
change it right now to be a derivative
with respect to displacement all I would
have to do is take this derivative and I
would take their SIPP we've done this a
lot in related rates have changed you
remember that sometimes we have like da
on dr but we're like we want we want it
the other way around so we just we just
turn it upside down right in this
context I can treat this just like a
fraction so I can say DT on DX equals 1
over 6 ok
and in this case I can now integrate
just like I did before but I'm
integrating quite differently on time
I'm going to end up with time what am i
integrating with respect to DX right so
with respect to X like so okay so
frequently you will be placed in the
position where you get given velocity
but what you actually have to do with
that is to then take the reciprocal and
then work with it ok again this is going
to be 6 but because I'm integrating with
respect to X it's going to be 1/6 X
right plus a constant probably worth me
just because I've done it all on the
same board
these constants may or may not be the
same so I'm gonna call this constant one
and I have ice renewing about there it
is okay I've got all those done let's
call this guy constant - okay so I've
got time in this case I still have my
initial condition that I used before and
I can pop it into here and I can say all
right let's let's put this in just like
I did earlier I'm gonna have 0 on the
right a 6 times 1 is that what I yep
plus C 2 so my constant in this case is
actually different it's going to be
negative 6 so I can pop that in and get
my original time equation a 6x minus 6
which of course you could verify like we
said before from here you could just
change the subject
but number one you can't always go
through this path number two sometimes I
want to go directly to this and I don't
want to go and repeat all of that work
okay